Illinois Senator Tammy Duckworth and her
newborn daughter well they've made
history again last week
Duckworth became the first senator to
give birth while in office
she brought baby Miley to work on
yesterday making her the first baby ever
allowed on the Senate floor during
official business Nancy Cordes on
Capitol Hill spoke to the senator Nancy
good morning I say welcome to 2018
people Wow that's right and the women
who make up a fifth of the Senate Gale
say that the change that made this
moment possible is about more than just
one mother it's about sending a message
to employers across the country that
there are some simple often overlooked
ways to accommodate working parents
Senator Duckworth daughter Miley made
history Thursday at the tender age of 10
days the two were surrounded by
well-wishers senators who never thought
much about the ban on babies until
Duckworth became the first sitting
senator to get pregnant and explained
her predicament I'm gonna take the time
that I need with my daughter but in the
middle of all that there might be days
when I have to you know we have a lot of
close votes right now that I need to
come in and and not let the people feel
annoyed down but then what do I do with
my baby women senators began working to
change the rule the men they say had
questions will she change the diaper on
the floor she will not do that couldn't
she just vote from the back where the
cloakroom is well she's lost both her
legs serving our country and the
cloakroom is not wheelchair accessible
unless you go through the Senate floor
on Wednesday the Senate unanimously
passed the resolution authorizing a
senator to bring a young son or daughter
of one day later the very situation
Duckworth warned about cropped up a
close vote on a NASA nominee from home
she began prepping Miley's outfit I made
sure she has a jacket so she doesn't
violate the Senate floor dress code
Duckworth tweeted I'm not sure what the
policy is on duckling onesies then the
two rushed in from maternity leave
Miley unfazed
phased by all the hoopla now this may
seem like a minor rule change but the
last time the Senate made an
accommodation like this it was 1997 when
they began allowing service dogs on the
floor and Nora one thing you don't hear
very often on the Senate floor when
Senator Duckworth and Miley entered the
room a collective Oh went up from the
Senate gallery a neat moment Wow
change long overdue and hopefully will
bring more ahhs and smiles to the Senate
chamber this thing she's only ten days
old I said all at that ten days welcome
to the world the first vote that's right
welcome